justement on nous attend le
correspondant de France 24 Gulliver
crack bonjour Gulliver Gulliver que
sait-on exactement de ces explosions
donc qui viennent de se produire à Kief
alors vous savez les autorités
ukrainiennes tentent toujours de ces
garder des données des précisions très
précises sur les lieux qui ont été
frappés ou il y a eu des explosions
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas communiquer
aux Russes trop rapidement si leur
frappe ont touché leur cible ou non mais
il semblerait que c'est sur la rue
volodymirska dans le centre de Kiev
c'est au-dessus de ce quartier là en
tout cas qu'on voit la fumée ce qu'il
faut retenir je pense le plus important
c'est que le QG des services de
renseignement ukrainien spi est situé
sur cette rue là pour le moment nous ne
pouvons pas préciser qu'est-ce qui a été
frappé exactement nous n'avons pas non
plus pour le moment des informations sur
d'éventuelles victimes mais je pense que
cela viendra rapidement il y avait eu
aussi ce matin des informations sur des
explosions plus loin en banlieue de Kiev
où selon les autorités des objets
d'infrastructure auraient été touchés
ces explosions là personnellement je ne
les ai pas entendu l'explosion dans le
centre-ville je l'ai entendu de là où je
me trouve c'était environ 2 km et demi
et beaucoup Gulliver crack en direct de
Kiev pour toutes ces dernières
précisions reviendra bien sûr vers vous
tout au long de nos prochaines éditions
pour faire un point sur la situation à
qui elle